so I have here the jawbone jambox say
wireless portable speaker and connects
wirelessly to your mobile phone so our
life is now on a mobile phone or phone
calls or music or video games everything
is from these devices and so with this
you can connect wirelessly to it it's
also a speakerphone so you get that full
experience of both the listening to
music and then a phone call comes in you
can answer it right there so do a
conference call right there with a bunch
of friends and stuff so we just launched
this in November been great it's been
selling like hotcakes at Apple it's been
phenomenal we really like it and it's
also an updatable device so you can plug
it in you can load new sounds on it new
applications we add firmware over time
so the device keeps getting better and
better over time so it's great you
literally when you turn it on you'll
feel it in your hand it shakes your hand
you just feel that kick right away it's
199 and it's available like I said an
apple best buy our website telecom
you